with the iPhone 15 lineup coming out
next month and it being near a year
since I got my 14 pro Max I wanted to
update you guys on five things that
really surprised me about this phone
using it since last September along with
three downsides that I was not expecting
now let's jump right into it and the
first thing I want to talk about is the
dynamic Island which was brand new for
the 14 pro phones now in my first review
of this phone I said that I wasn't
really using it very much now sure it's
nice that we don't have that ugly Notch
that is protruding but it also cuts out
more of the video if you like to watch
in full screen so it's kind of a toss-up
and I was hoping that more applications
would start to support it well in the
last Almost year now I absolutely love
this thing one of my most common uses is
just tapping it when I'm listening to
music music or podcasts which is all the
time to get controls or have a quick
shortcut into the app and that is just
really nice and along with that I often
use timers and to see that countdown
being built right in is really handy the
same thing with screen recording having
that little red dot that pops up telling
me that I'm recording that is really
nice and in general I would say that it
would be really hard for me to go back
to not having a dynamic Island now
unfortunately not a ton of apps have
come out to support them at least major
ones for example Google Maps still does
not use that and because of that I'm
actually using Apple Maps now fairly
often just so I could see that turn by
turn notification now the second thing I
absolutely love is the always on display
I loved it in my first review and I even
showed you guys how to go in and create
a custom mode where it has a dark
background so it's not as bright bright
and it saves battery life but over the
last I don't know half a year I stopped
using it I think Apple has made some
optimizations as far as the battery life
and I just like how it looks where the
screen looks like it's pretty much on
just in a dimmed mode and I love being
able to just look over and glance at my
notifications what is happening if
something is playing there in the
background to have quick controls this
is another thing that I could not go
back to not having it I think Apple did
an excellent job with this and has been
one of the biggest reasons to upgrade as
for number three this is something that
a lot of reviewers don't talk about and
that is the reception cellular
performance and speed now I've done many
videos testing different generations of
phones and the really sweet thing about
the 14 pro Max is that I have fairly
good reception in my basement whereas
many of my friends that have even a 13
Pro Max well they really don't get a
signal and that sucks they have to use
like Wi-Fi calling and that is a major
benefit because of the better modems
that are in here maybe a little bit more
power optimization not only in my
basement but even in other areas uh more
rural areas the signal is actually there
when in the past it wasn't so that is
something that you need to consider if
you're thinking about upgrading maybe
you want to wait another year if you
have areas where you have bad reception
upgrading is going to make that better
or you might even get a signal when you
didn't have one in the past now number
four is the removal of the Sim slot I
hated this when it came out I talked
about the issues I had family members
that had issues uh getting self-service
on their new phone because they can't
just pop a SIM card in there drop call
issues but now it has been working
flawlessly now my wife's 14 Pro Max had
some issues she did drop but we had to
get it replaced so I had to transfer the
E SIM from her phone to a temporary one
and then back and forth and it was
extremely quick super easy and simple
and I did not miss having that SIM card
slot it was basically just as fast as
having to you know remove it swap it but
I didn't have to really do anything just
place two phones together so I think the
removal of the SIM card is a non-issue
anymore and that is one thing that
really surprised me and asked for number
five part of this really blew my mind
and that is a 48 megapixel camera sensor
now when Apple announced this they
showed it off they made a huge deal
about it they showed off the 2x crap
mode saying it was basically lossless
and I was a big skeptic but in our
Hands-On comparisons we showed how
Apple's 48 megapixel destroys Samsung's
108 and even their brand new over 200
megapixel sensor now one issue I had was
the fact that you have to record in
apple raw and then the file size is
massive and I showed you guys how you
can have a shortcut that will make it
into heifs or hacs giving you the full
resolution but at the same time making
the file sizes really small and while
some reviewers have said that they
almost never take photos in that mode I
am doing it way more often than I
expected so much so that we're taking
Family Photos I'm the one that's taking
it with my phone and then sending that
image to everybody else because it looks
so amazingly good now with that that 2x
crop mode I'm using now all the time I
love that focal length more so than the
3x lens and the quality is surprisingly
good leading me into video I love using
the 2x in video mode because it gives
you more compression it just looks
really really nice and with that this
year for the first time ever I'm using
my phone for even YouTube videos that we
may make quite often I'm even mixing in
shots with my professional Sony cameras
and as long as the lighting is good they
match really well I'm also using the 4K
cinematic mode that was enabled this
year in some shots but in a lot of shots
because of the large 48 megapixel sensor
I don't have to because you have a
natural blur that cannot get messed up
due to the algorithm not functioning
properly so this new camera update has
been the biggest camera update in my
opinion ever and if you want to get
better photo quality I would highly
recommend this or of course the upcoming
iPhones that also are gonna have 48
megapixel and now we got to talk about
some of the issues and the first one I
want to cover is battery degradation now
a few months ago I made a video giving
you guys tips on how to make your
iPhone's battery lasts a long time and
at that time my iPhone was at 99
capacity now I am at 91. if fell off a
cliff in Angelica's phone that she has a
14 pro hers was at 100 now she is at 92.
and with that Aaron from zollotech just
posted on Twitter that he's at 90
percent and usually at this time of year
he would be at 100 and not his 13 Pro
Max which he used for a full year as his
daily phone and then the last year he
used it for YouTube videos that's at 98.
and with that
um as far as the battery life it has
been getting worse just noticing it day
to day now I don't know if that's
because of the always-on display maybe
it's because of the new 2000 it's super
high brightness screen that will heat up
quite a bit but this is definitely a
disappointment and I also feel like
maybe Apple Engineers are doing
something weird where at first it stays
close at 100 but now that we're close to
the new phones coming out now it's
showing its true capacity it's dropping
Like a Rock to give you another and set
attentive to upgrade you guys let me
know your thoughts down below but this
definitely sucks and something I was not
expecting now for downside number two
that has to be overheating we talk about
this every year and it has gotten better
and when I first got the 14 pro Max we
were still in really hot temperatures
here and even though we did have some
dimming it was way better than before
but recently my screen dimming has
gotten way worse and I know other people
have mentioned this as well it is not
only Demi more often but it's getting uh
even more dim where the screen gets you
know a lot dimmer compared to B4 and
that 2000 nit ultra high brightness
which is amazing when it does work well
it is not working that well because it's
dropping and I don't know if this also
is like the thermal layer they have not
being as effective but I want Apple to
do something better kind of like what
Samsung has put more focus on thermals
as especially now that we have so much
performance and such high brightness
screens and as for the third downside
that I was not expecting that has to be
the other camera specifically the selfie
camera now the 14 lineup got brand new
12 megapixel sensors that are larger
they have a different pixel density
layout it's now an F 1.5 lens and some
websites said that this is the biggest
selfie camera update ever but over the
last year I've just been getting more
and more disappointed in the images that
I am getting they just don't look good
and Android phones have way better
selfie cameras that are destroying them
I want Apple to put in either a 32
megapixel or maybe a 48 if they want
them to match to really give us a nice
boost in just the quality and detail of
those photos because other brands are
just so much better you guys let me know
your thoughts have you been happy with
them or does Apple need to step this up
so there you guys go overall I've been
very happy with this phone but some of
those things are annoying and it sucks
to see it get worse as time goes on go
ahead and click one of those videos over
there to check them out click the circle
above to subscribe there's been Max and
I'll see you in the next video
foreign